JOE MARINI: All right.
Hello everyone.
This is Joe Marini.
Welcome to another edition of
Chrome Apps Office Hours.
Today I thought we would
do something
a little bit different.
If you've been following along,
you probably noticed
that Chrome packaged apps have
been getting a lot of
attention in the press lately.
We recently turned on our
initial roll out of Chrome
packaged apps in the Chrome Web
Store, if you're on the
dev channel on Windows
or Chrome OS.
And so the press took notice.
And as a result, we've been
getting a lot of attention
from some new developers, who
want to learn about what
Chrome packaged apps are.
So the last several shows we've
done have been some
relatively advanced topics.
And I thought today
I'd do something
a little bit different.
And maybe do a little
bit of a rewind.
And do a quick intro of packaged
apps and their
structure for some of the newer
developers out there.
If you have any questions of the
stuff that I'm going to be
showing you, go ahead and post
them in the comments section
of the tab there.
And we will monitor the comments
to see if there are
any questions.
Not a very long show today.
So if you have any questions,
please get them in.
And we will get them answered.
Let's jump over to the diagrams
here and show you a
little bit about packaged apps
and what their structure is.
So packaged apps are built using
HTML5, just like regular
web apps are.
So to do that, you just
build your content as
you normally would.
You'd build your
HTML, your CSS.
You've got your JavaScript
code.
Whatever other assets that
comprise your app.
You don't do anything
really different.
You just build your
app normally.
There's a few things you
have to worry about.
You can't do things like inline
JavaScript, like in
your script tags.
You can't use inline event
handlers, things like that.
But for the most part, you just
build the web app just
the way that you always would.
Now on top of that, packaged
apps, you just simply layer
some additional information
on top of them.
So for example, we ask you to
put some infrastructure around
your existing web code.
We ask you to make a
manifest.json file.
And that's just a JSON code
structure that defines the
information that the
platform needs.
And there's something called a
background HTML file and a
JavaScript file.
I've got it called main.js
here, but you can call it
pretty much whatever you want.
So this infrastructure is what
tells Chrome that this
particular application
is a packaged app.
And provides the necessary
information for the runtime to
be able to run the apps
and read it's
permissions, and so on.
So the manifest.json file
as I mentioned, it's a
straightforward JSON
structure.
And in the JSON code, you do
things like specify what the
name of the app is, its version,
what permissions it
has, that kind of stuff.
The main.js file is a little
bit different.
It simply defines the entry
points into the application.
So this is where you
do things like
register your event handlers.
And create Windows.
And so on and so forth.
Now that we have an idea of what
the structure of packaged
apps looks like, let's get out
of the slides here and jump
over to some code.
And if you want to follow
along with me, I'm just
looking at the code that's
here on our Google Chrome
GitHub repo.
If you go to the
chrome-app-samples repo in our
top level Google Chrome folder
there, you'll see what I'm
talking about.
I'm going to scroll
on down here.
And I'm going to open up the
Hello World folder right here.
And you can see, inside this
folder we've got some code.
So I'm going to quickly open
up the manifest.json file
here, so we can see what
its contents are.
And this is intended to be
a really simple sample.
So nothing too complex
is going on here.
You can see that it specifies
a Manifest version.
And the current version of
Manifest files is two.
And there's the name
of the app, which
happens to be Hello World.
This version field right here
is for my purposes.
This is the version of my app.
And the Chrome Web Store uses
this field to figure out what
the newest version of your app
is, so that it knows when it's
doing an update check for
people who have your app
installed, whether it needs to
push out and update or not.
I happen to have a minimum
Chrome version specified here.
So this is the minimum version
of Chrome that the user has to
have installed in order
for this app to run.
And there's an icon section.
And down here is
an app section.
And in the app section,
there's a field called
Background.
And here in the scripts
subfield, there's a main.js.
I happen to call the
file main.js.
You can call it whatever
you want.
And I would normally host
this inside the
background.html page.
But that's actually optional.
If you don't provide us one of
those, we'll just simply auto
generate one for you.
So you really only need the
manifest and the JavaScript
file, which handles the
bootstrapping and other event
handling of the app's
infrastructure.
So that's the manifest file.
Let's jump back out and take
a look at the main.js file.
And I'll scroll down
the code here.
So here in this JavaScript
file, the application is
adding a listener for the
onLaunched event.
The onLaunched event is on the
Chrome App runtime space.
And the callback function right
here that's going to get
called when the onLaunched event
fires is simply checking
to see how big screen is, and
then deciding where to put the
window it's about to create.
And so it comes up with the
width and the height.
Those are just hard coded.
It uses the screen width and
screen height to center the
window on the page.
So I call Chrome app, and then
we have a window name space
right here, .create.
And that creates the window,
given the index.html page I'm
going to use as the
main window.
And then I give it
some properties.
I give it some bounds.
And you can see here that I'm
using the screen width and
height to figure out where
the app is going to go.
Now to test this out, what you
do as a developer is load up
Chrome-- so start Chrome--
and then go to the Extensions
tab in your Chrome settings.
So down here--
I'm doing this on a Pixel, but
you can get to this page
easily on any one of
the platforms.
So under Settings, I'm
going to click on
the Extensions tab.
And here in the Extensions
tab, you can see I've got
Developer Mode turned
on here in the
upper right hand corner.
And once I turn Developer Mode
on, I'll get these buttons.
Load Unpacked Extension, Packed
Extensions, so on.
So if you click on Load Unpacked
Extension, you'll get
a file dialogue that lets you
choose the application that
you want to load to test.
So I loaded up Hello
World right here.
And there's a couple of ways I
can launch this to test it.
I can click on the little
Launch link right here.
Or I can go into my new
tab experience.
Right here, I've got my new tab,
and I can scroll over to
my installed apps.
But because I'm on a Chrome OS
device that's got the latest
version of Chrome running, and
I've got my launcher down here
in the Chrome OS bar, my app
just shows up here in the
launcher once I've loaded it.
And it shows up this way
whether I've loaded it
unpacked or whether I've
installed it from
the Chrome Web Store.
It's a really handy little
feature to be able to load
these unpacked folders of code
while you're doing your
iteration and testing.
So I'll just go ahead
launch that app.
And you can see that the
window comes up.
It's centered on the
screen, and this is
the Hello world example.
So pretty straightforward
example.
Let's take a look at something
that's a little bit more
involved and actually requires
some permissions.
So let's go back to the
samples on our GitHub.
And this time I'm going
to go over to
the file system example.
So right here and file
system access.
I'm going to click there
and we'll scroll down.
Let's take a look at the
manifest JSON for this one.
All right, we'll scroll
down a little bit.
So you can see that this
manifest file is slightly more
advanced than the one
for Hello World.
The first properties are
all pretty similar.
They're pretty standard,
actually.
You give it a name,
and a version, and
the Manifest version.
Those are always there.
And then down here, you can
see I've got a permissions
field right here.
Which is asking Chrome
for the permission
to use a file system.
And in this case, we want to
be able to write file data.
And we also want to be able
to retain entries.
So the Chrome runtime lets you
hold on to file entries that
the user has previously opened
in your application.
And this comes in handy when
you want to do things like
implement a recently used
file menu, for example.
And we're also asking for
access to the storage
permission, so we can
use our sandbox
storage to store files.
There's also a File
Handlers field.
And this is where we associate
file handler MIME types.
And in this case, It's not
using file extensions.
But you can also specify three,
or four, or whatever
character file extensions.
So that when the user wants
to open a file--
either by double-clicking
on it, or
right-clicking, whatever--
the Chrome runtime knows that
your app is one of the
potential candidates for
handling a file of that type.
So slightly more advanced.
In this case, it's actually
asking for permissions.
Let's jump over to the
documentation for all this.
The documentation for Chrome
packaged apps is on our
developer.chrome.com/apps
site.
And that will take you to this
welcome page right here.
I'm going to click on this
link for "understand the
architecture." So this page
explains all about how the
architecture of Chrome
packaged apps works.
It runs through the life
cycle, what kinds of
events there are.
It gives you a high
level overview.
For more detailed information
on things like the structure
and APIs that are available to
you as part of the overall
life cycle and architecture of
your app, I'm going to scroll
down here to the Chrome
JavaScript APIs link.
And let's fire up the
app runtime docs.
And you can see here, this is
where the documentation for
some of the various runtime
related events are kept.
So here's the one for the
onLaunched listener.
There's also one for
onRestarted.
So if your app has been
restarted because of an update
or whatever.
And you can see down here,
there's also various sample
apps that show how to
use these events.
So the Chrome runtime, the
name's basically used for
handling typical life cycle
events in your application.
And this area of the
documentation right here,
actually, the Chrome APIs,
this is where all of the
JavaScript APIs that are
specific to the Chrome
platform are listed.
So if you're new developer, you
need to understand this.
We use HTML5 and related
JavaScript APIs wherever they
provide a feature that
the platform needs.
We don't try to invent new
things or reinvent the wheel
if we don't have to.
We then create Chrome API that
fill in various needs of the
system where HTML doesn't
provide a solution.
For example, we have the ability
to take advantage of
Chrome's syncing architecture.
If you've ever used Chrome on
multiple computers and you're
signed in, you'll notice that
your bookmarks appear across
various instances of Chrome.
You, as a packaged app
developer, can take
advantage of that.
Now obviously, HTML doesn't
have a feature for that.
That's a Chrome feature.
So we provide a Chrome API.
So that's a quick introduction
to the
structure of packaged apps.
I'm going to take a quick look
over at and stream to see if
there are any questions.
It doesn't appear
that there are.
So if you do think of any,
you can always find me.
I'm Joe Marie on G+.
I'm also on Twitter,
Joe Marini.
And you can always leave
the comments here
in the YouTube tab.
We monitor the forums
for questions.
So please feel free to leave
questions, and we'll respond
to them as they come in.
See you next time on Chrome
Apps Office hours
for packaged apps.
Hope you enjoyed the
introduction to the packaged
apps structure, all you
knew developers.
So get out there and
start building some
great packaged apps.